bota o pessoal aqui quem fala é o dark
sejam muito bem vindos na maioria linhas
840 datado e o que consumimos a porta é
duas caixas que não faz idéia do que são
vamos ver o que tem uma história pessoal
eu não faço ideia do que é coisa de
ninguém entregue comida já 70 tarde
portanto deve ser alguma coisa
[Música]
uma falha nas falas landa não rocha está
mostrando por que não andam eles que eu
sou a pessoa que é um então porque eu
sou feio é essa misteriosa
eu não tenho cara fala é nem pode ser um
fada sininho pode ser uma falha macho e
que vamos abrir cinco meses e ver o que
tá ali fora espero que não seja nada mal
espero que não seja uma prenda do itaó
vamos ver vamos descobrir agora juntos e
já deixe você pega aqui embaixo de sua
mãe quero só dizer que o comitê estarão
mixta caminhão caiu eu não disse se você
bater um recorde de 30 mil está em mora
nenhum vídeo no começo para unix aí
portanto está a caminho e infelizmente
nosso time estava muito doente eu e voz
misteriosa portanto é por isso que nós
vamos abrandar os vídeos porque o clima
muito colocar um vídeo por dia méxico
podem vir pela minha voz ainda estou um
pouco doente está complicada e os filhos
vão ser muito em breve com muita coisa
eu estou com o que parece bola de 5 -
embora
só para que as câmaras têm dois
cachorros aqui e não tem nenhuma forma
por tantas que segure o usuário já que o
premiado álbum tempo conseguir a vaga
logo a seguir suas caixas negras
[Música]
são brinquedos que o carro do batman
eu nem quer saber eu vou fazer pra casa
a link to confirmou que o filme batman
não acha difícil de se jogar e não estou
falando agora eu já sei já sei que vai
entregar esta casa já estava à espera
mas é óbvio que nós mais brinquedos e
conhecido aqui cai dentro é que vão
subir até agora olha só podia ser uma
tela e enviar estes brinquedos para nós
duas caras já estão aqui em casa meu
incrível tem muito bem tendo a equipa
deixou duas faixas gigantes vai deixar
as casas aqui porque sofre uma coisa mas
não só tem que o batman nem a sua mota é
isso aí então disparar que qualquer
coisa eu acho que é tipo seu gancho deu
mas vamos ver esses quito e que tem mais
ter o meu deus não é eu sei que o carro
caso do batom por isso é incrível coisas
também campos fará coisas aqui o som mis
seis mísseis tenham alcance dos mísseis
meu deus é incrível pois é uma caixa
vazia
tentei que mais olha isso tenho que já
se excluir que tem problema de vila e
tem muitas vezes em condições pelo que
parece só para quem é fã dele se é que
temos o juca isso é clara tem aqui uma
ilustração e que o lucro
o alvo mas quando chegaram aqui também
imaginext olha aí só que o ibope
olha só se coloque também é pk
transformável olha só o também bispo
antónio é muito brinquedo que dizes que
natal claramente que estão os melhores
brinquedos para o natal portanto pessoas
faz porque está incrível só vou poder de
queima e tantos brinquedos mas eu tô
curioso primeiro aqui como funciona o
clima ea moto do barco rock fest vitória
incrível eu vou deixar aqui o link
intitulado eu falei então que matou o
envio para nós misteriosa mas por que o
dunga já o tcheco então ok só isso é o
nosso jogo é e meu deus eu tenho dentro
de mim tomar é um desejo que eu falei
olha isso tem muitas situações também o
projeto viva já pensei que não era assim
tão articulado mas é muito articulado
para eu ficar tranqüilo mesmo assim o
fato é que o futebol é flexível também
ok eu quero ver agora então é mulher
maravilha boró
meu deus deve estar incrível também
espero que seja tão antiquada né com
certeza vai ser a matéria não me falou
que não é tão fácil ae
olha só e tem grandes botas sim senhor
enquanto a roupa estava igual a ela mas
também de cabeça os braços meu méxico
tem muitas situações é uma tv que acorda
dela e pergunta que toda a gente faz
quando se trata de ex figueirense e dou
muito valor a isso só quem é esse é o
segundo com um pé porque elas podem ser
muito articuladas não se agüenta em pé
não é um action figures série portanto
vamos saber se a mattel fez aqui no meu
trabalho e vai ao a
lá eu não fui lá leite o avai dos rostos
dos fiéis estão prontos para convencer o
site inglês mal não é manter um momento
em que a irmã no final de 2004 até tempo
atrás isso é muito louco porque assim
tem muita resistência o boné que você
vive tão curtinho na então taça uefa
toca aí vamos agora vir vamos ver um
carro que o fim do acúmulo olhem só para
isso está incrível
o carro está incrível para o avião com
lança mísseis e lança mísseis
só quero só aí é que está o nosso bate
móbil olha pessoal do curioso pra ver
como é que os times funcionam mas vamos
dar aqui uma olhadela no carro que eu
acho que eu tenho aqui segredo vem
construir as rodas até e ii
não temos pressa quer ver eu acho que a
obra que não o lado abre mesmo assim
estou bem aqui mas sempre provado mas
não consegue entrar aqui em casa eu vou
tentar encerrar o jogo aqui dentro da
cabeça mesmo foi entrando no jogo que
entro aí eu encaixo mesmo bem como é que
funciona agora as missas eu acho que é
só
encaro assim exato em que o míssil
lançar mísseis
o assunto foi em 2006
olha isso espera que os mísseis em 3
do ó destruidor de joca a acalma de que
está tudo bem
juca está tudo bem que mal tem havido
qualquer coisa que eu mais gostei foi o
mesmo os mísseis que dá pra entrar no
estádio e equilíbrio para o nosso
batmóvel temos também aqui bate moka
olha só o incrível olha que traz é que
temos a passagem do bloco no meu esta
incrível por também não ter sequela e
tem aqui uma capa em sido rolar a cabeça
é como campeão e não se agora sim só o
nosso button rubinho vai poder ter o seu
nono dentro disso o iphan bologna
botinha agora
ok vamos lá os caras volta às vezes
funciona tão bem como no caso da minha
exposição vai ser incrível país o bairro
negro laka isso é que nós temos todo
esse pessoal coleção nós temos aqui o
batom vinho também a mata do barco e
temos a figura do batman
o show é mulher maravilha inclusive eu
acho que nós temos muito mais figura só
que eu vou confirmar aqui aqui outras
podem assinar aqui tem super homem o
flash também mateus vocês não querem
dinheiro faz tempo que o dof ninguém pra
mim o próximo papel
acho até mesmo ele vai ficar aqui no
moda do batman
o jogo era aquilo e deus vai subir os
briquetes imaginext civil e nós também
porque nós temos aqui é que temos base
cavernas solo triste aqui vou tentar
perceber como é que funciona já
demonstrado então aqui temos base não
vai subir a equipe no rio voador e vai
ser aqui em cima e agora só vamos armar
a nossa beckett é que nesta posição
agora é soltar o ato mas vejo o que
acontece
[Aplausos]
palavras nada sakic 15 mil nós
conseguimos descobrir o tesouro
olha aí é que tá uma armadura incrível é
que nós temos uma semi cisco button ele
pode usar em 321 aqui embaixo nós temos
um portão de beckham é automática aí em
cima ficou duas horas de um do barco não
dizem que algumas armas que uma pistola
nós conseguimos ter também aqui um
escudo de lu é só colocar o saque e eu
vou usar isso é um absurdo para treinar
aqui ensina para aí aqui dentro da
prisão do juca ali quando batman
prisional onde eu quero aqui dentro do
terreno de jogo tão impressionada
a equipe espanhola de button para
controlar um botão específico suas
câmeras pode ficar atento aqui quando eu
quiser sair do benfica deve simplesmente
está tudo seguro fechado imaginext deve
ter muita coisa pois por aqui pois
quando vocês quiserem ok vamos ver então
outro brinquedo que eu também quero ver
nós não estamos aqui também o bebop da
image next eu acho que o baixo só
automático de um comando o controle do
outro portanto vai ser interessante
ganhar aqui no maiô que vai acontecer 31
com ela mesmo olha ai ai ai está
controlada que ficou com é nosso time é
muito bom jogador
na época eu tenho que botar eles fazem
sons fazem som de músicos que também uma
metralhadora quatro podem usar um pedaço
também no olho e outra coisa tem aqui o
batman dentro aí pq o fato de vocês
podem colocar aqui em cima e eu acho que
eu volto muito feliz em voltar agora
exato eleitores o partido que quer 15
mil incrível isso que foi cheia de água
eu vou vir aqui por cima e nós vamos
colocar estas fichinhas que também
vieram com o brinquedo para aqui vamos
colocar o bafana por cima talvez esses
países vão ter desfilado em 321 apontar
de explorá-los ok vou esperar o marcinho
é só clicar aqui estão atrás três
resumirá à vontade de explorar a imagem
de equilíbrio nós aqui eu não vou
esquecer é uma figurinha também é bem
rigorosa a namorada do barco eu acho que
é só você tem vários colecionáveis até
vocês podem ter várias personagens e eu
já tenho a equipe com uma motinha eu
acho que elas farão um ensaio olha só 32
o ganhar e só espero que vocês tenham
gostado aqui de tudo o que mata é o
envio para nós como o que mais está aí a
nossa festa aqui e disse olha aí todo
discutindo aqui no carro mas pra mim sem
dúvida
dúvida o carro do batman é lindo né quem
ofereceu o carro que o juca não é tudo
mesmo até o envio para mim mais uma
estrela de tudo meu turma é um todo e
não alguém só para quase ninguém está
aqui neste vídeo muito obrigado a mattel
mesmo já sabem se quiser ver mais vídeos
deste ano como também em baixo a jaguar
é comenta e como eu gosto mais um
favorito de vice e embaixo passou esse
comentário vou ver no meu acho que eu
faço e só fica é esta é a próxima